north las vegas planning to offer
diversionary programs that will really
focus on rehabilitation for people
that are accused of low level crimes 8
news now reporter madison kimbrough
spoke with the city along with the chief
of police about this brand new plan
and why this is so vital especially now
in our community she joins us live in
the newsroom with more madison
yes this is all a part of the north las
vegas municipal court expansion
this new program is a way for people who
committed non-violent crimes
to get the resources that they need so
they don't have to become
repeat offenders we're not looking to
lock people up and throw away the key
we're looking to
enhance our community and make better
connections and
better outcomes for the people in our
community north las vegas municipal
court
is expanding and it couldn't have come
at a better time
they've created what's being called a
diversionary program that will assist
low-level offenders in getting the
resources they need to stay
out of jail we see a large number of
mental health cases
substance abuse domestic violence and in
a lot of those cases while they made a
bad decision
and there should be a consequence for
that putting them
into the justice system isn't ultimately
going to help them or help the community
in any productive long-term way
the program is meant to address the
issues at hand of why the person
ended up in court in the first place and
then assist them accordingly
the diversionary program will allow
those folks who qualify to
get the services they need be it mental
health services
addiction treatment community service
so they can give back really address the
issues and if they do that successfully
then in most cases their record will be
expunged
court will be able to determine whether
a rehabilitative program would better
serve the person
or if incarceration is the best solution
this is something that we put in place
and it just happens to work out with the
great timing of everything
mental health issues and homelessness
has always been a problem and i feel
it's more prevalent because of the
pandemic
and chief oheda also mentioned that by
reducing the number of repeated arrests
that in turn will allow officers to
respond faster to more prevalent and
violent crimes
the court expansion is expected to
launch in the late spring
early summer reporting in the newsroom
madison kimbrough 8 news now